all right big headline on drudge
speaking of Taylor Swift headline is
Maga goes to war on Swift and that links
to uh this Rolling Stone article which
says singer songwriter Taylor Swift
hasn't even endorsed President Joe Biden
for re-election yet that hasn't stopped
members of magal land's Upper Crust from
plotting to declare as one source close
to Donald Trump calls it a holy war on
the pop meast star especially if she
ends up publicly backing the Democrats
in the 2024 election according to three
people familiar with the matter Trump
loyalists working on or close to the
former president campaign longtime Trump
allies and right-wing media and an array
of outside advisers to the ex- president
have long taken it as a given that Swift
will eventually endorse Biden as she did
in 2020 indeed several of these
Republicans and conservative media
figures have discussed the matter with
Trump over the past few
months um he but she hasn't endorsed
anyone yet but now they're attacking her
okay now this is rolling stone which is
a a propaganda rag that nobody should
take seriously and they're quoting
unnamed sources around Donald Trump
which historically means that it's it's
it's nonsense you shouldn't trust it but
in this case we see that this war on
Taylor Swift is already playing out you
know we know that this is happening it's
happening in public in the past few
weeks conservative commentators have
started attacking Taylor Swift um pretty
consistently and they're saying that her
popularity is a sop I mean this is
something you see all over Twitter now
uh I've even heard that she's a CIA
asset you know I think they were talking
about that on Fox News a couple nights
ago so it has been um an allout uh
assault metaphorically on Taylor Swift
from some corners of the right at least
certainly not everyone or even close to
a majority but let me let me just say a
few things about this and then uh and
then and then uh I'll move on first of
all if everything is a sop then nothing
is a sop okay we we we've gotten to a
point as conservatives where just every
reflexively everything that happens is
autom atically a
scop and
um the problem is that there are scops
that happen but now when just that is
your reflexive reaction to everything it
doesn't mean anything
anymore and and there's no need to
postulate a scop for things that can be
easily explained without them it's kind
of been a theme on the show this
week yeah there plent there are plenty
of conspiracy theorists theor theories
that have uh have validity there are
plenty that have been proven
true
but if you have something that can be
easily explained without a conspiracy
theory then we we you don't need the
conspiracy theory so Taylor Swift's
popularity is one of those things okay
it's not engineered by the CIA or
whatever millions of girls and women
love her
music because it resonates with them
they they like it I mean that's it okay
she she's an attractive woman who writes
songs that other women women really like
and that's the whole story um that's why
she's popular right now I don't I don't
get the music I don't get it person it's
not my type of music doesn't resonate
with me I think her music is dumb um I
also think that it's it's gotten worse
now I'm not I you know maybe a somewhat
unfair assessment on my end because I
don't really listen but from a from a
30,000 foot bird's eye
perspective well Birds wouldn't be
30,000 feet in the air anyway for 10,000
feet um it seems to me like the Music's
Got like she used to do the pop country
you know uh acoustic ballad type music
and and now it's more of the uh hookie
pop dance stuff that she's doing so but
anyway the music isn't for me and I
don't like it and that's fine the point
is that you don't need to look at Taylor
Swift and think to yourself what's going
on here who is this person why is she
all over the TV there there must be some
sort of conspiracy of foot how do we
explain this what's happening
no she's just very if you want to know
like before thinking about the CIA and
is she an asset is she just go ask
literally any woman under the age of 35
or
40 like what do people like about Taylor
Swift she'll tell even if she's not a
Taylor Swift fan she'll be able to
explain it she's not going to be
confused um she's popular because she's
popular people like her you know she she
is our Michael
Jackson and I don't like Michael Jackson
either
but you know it's this this
is in the modern uh day age you know we
we this is what happens we have pop
stars and they become very famous as
long as pop music and the entertainment
modern entertainment industry has
existed there have always been people
like that now is Taylor Swift uh a
big-time lib will she vote for Biden
will she tell other people to vote for
Biden uh does she hate Trump yes yes yes
and yes you know of course so in that
way she's exactly the same as almost
anyone else who's even vaguely relevant
in the entertainment
industry um which is a problem that's a
long-standing problem we have as
conservatives that every single person
the entertainment industry who's even a
little bit
relevant is a leftist now we all know
that but that's why I don't get these
right- wiers on Twitter who are digging
up you I mentioned this today and
someone sent me oh yeah how do you
explain this and it was a it was a uh a
tweet of Taylor Swift's from 2020 when
she was criticizing
Trump and they're reposting the Tweet
like see you see she's a leftist I told
yeah we know like obviously she is no
one is denying that of course she is you
don't need well you see in 2020 it's
you're saying she's not a CIA asset but
but then in 2020 she criticized Trump
can you explain that
what there's like millions of people in
this country who don't like Trump and
critics are they all CIA assets is that
is that the only way to explain why a
30-year-old pop star doesn't like Trump
the only way to explain it is that the
CIA has gotten to her I mean come on
this year make life insurance part of
your financial plan start shopping now
with policy genius and find the right
policy to protect your family policy
genius makes it easy to compare life
insurance quotes from top companies and
find your lowest price don't get ripped
off by life insurance policy genius
makes you uh helps you compare your
options from top companies their team of
license experts is on hand to help talk
you through it there are no added fees
and your personal information is kept
private I have a life insurance plan you
should to it was super satisfying to
check life insurance off of my to-do
list so go get it done and get it done
with policy genius these guys are great
at what they do they make the process
seamless and stressfree a good life
insurance plan can uh give you a piece
of mind that if something happens to you
your family will be able to cover
mortgage payments College costs or other
expenses life insurance through your
workplace may not offer enough
protection for your family's needs and
it won't follow you if you leave your
job since life insurance typically gets
more expensive as we age now is the time
to buy policy genius makes the process
so much easier with policy genius you
can find life insurance policies that
start at just $292 per year for $1
million of coverage some options offer
same day approval and avoid unnecessary
medical exam save time and money
and give your family a financial safety
net with policy genius head to policy
genius.com Walsh or click the link in
the description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's policygenius.com
wolsh what's the plan here if you're
worried about the sway that Taylor Swift
will have over the
election and we when we talked about
this a few days ago I I now they're
saying 18% or whatever it was in the
poll are saying they'll be more likely
to vote if Taylor Swift they will be
more likely to vote for whoever Taylor
Swift endorses I don't think it's really
18% I hope it's not 18% that just seems
way too high um but she does have a sway
over the election it's not a good
thing I I don't like having a political
system where pop stars can uh have a
vastly disproportionate impact on the
outcome I don't like that but that's
that's what we have
and my question is how is obsessively
attacking her a smart or effective
counter strategy how is that going to
work exactly so you get a bunch of Fox
News Boomers all upset about Taylor
Swift and then
what and then what what's step
two like attacking Taylor Swift is only
appealing to to people who are already
hardcore Trump supporters so no one else
okay that no Taylor Swift fan is gonna
see a right-wing influencer on Twitter
criticizing her and go you know what
that influencer is right Taylor Swift is
terrible okay that goes for me I mean I
wouldn't I don't I'm not going to call
myself an influencer I don't like the
term but if I went all uh you know guns
are blazing at Taylor Swift it doesn't
matter there would not be a single
Taylor Swift fan who would hear me say
Taylor Swift you shouldn't listen her
none of them are gonna hear me say you
know Matt Walsh I'll go with him on this
one it's not gonna happen it just is not
gonna happen
so what's the plan what's the strategy
here what what's the
win um also and this to me is the main
thing and this is why I find the whole
thing annoying you know uh is if I were
to compile a list of all of the most
objectionable morally debased degenerate
pop stars who are the most toxic and the
most harmful to Young Minds and are
contributing the most to our cultural
rot Taylor Swift would not make the top
50 and if she would make your top 50
list I I envy your ignorance okay if you
were to make a if you personally were to
make a list of the most degenerate most
harmful pop stars and Taylor Swift is in
your top five well then you are you are
blissfully ignorant of just how bad
things are out there I wish I wish I I
wish to God that we lived in a culture
where Taylor Swift was one of the worst
most most objectionable pop stars I wish
that was the case like I wish we had the
luxury to to be uh complaining about her
I
wish but it's not the case okay she
she's not even close I mean she she
doesn't she's not close to the top 50
her her music is downright wholesome
compared to all of the other pop music
that exists almost all of it like she
writes songs pretty much what does she
write about she writes about uh falling
in love and breaking up she writes songs
about breaking up with her boyfriend
okay and and these These are classic
music themes okay now sure it's kind of
vapid for a 32-year-old to still be
singing about breaking up with her
boyfriend like she's in high school but
so what I mean do you realize what kind
of explicit overt messaging is in many
other Mega hit
songs like do you realize
what the some of the top charting songs
for years now what is in the those songs
what those songs are saying what kids
are listening to and repeating and
singing along
to you've got someone like sexy red or
whatever you know outwardly telling
women to be and glorifying drug
use and crime and gang violence and so
on and so on and and and Taylor Swift is
who we're worried about it's like if
it's like if you decided that the worst
thing that kids watch on their screens
are 1990s Disney movies instead of you
know hard core
pornography okay it's like if you were
going through uh a kid's book your kid's
book bag and you found a a a pack of
bubble gum and you also found a crack
pipe and then you were like hey what is
this I told you we don't chew gum in
this house too much sugar it's
like I If everything else is going well
with your kid then you could complain
about the the bubble gum but if you got
the crack and that's that probably
should be the headline here I don't know
if
uh I don't know if you have room or the
luxury as apparent to be worried about
the bubble gun and I thing is speaking
of pornography that's what a lot of Pop
modern pop music is it's like it's
pornographic it's full-on pornographic
it's basically 50 Shades of Gray but set
to music and aimed at middle schoolers
and with an added dose of thuggery and
crime
glorification and Taylor Swift is the
villain on Fox news
though um right she uses very little
profanity she she doesn't make for the
most most part explicit songs keeps her
clothes on for the most part by pop
music standards keeps her cloth on
uh one of the top charting songs of the
last two years you may remember featured
a woman with face tattoos describing in
detail her bodily
orices in fact there have been that's
that is a common theme now in pop music
there have been multiple hit songs that
have that have had that same
theme okay and
so these are the kinds of
degenerate creeps we have making music
that like 12-year-olds are listening
to and yet Taylor Swift singing about
breaking up with their boyfriend is the
thing that we're that we uh are
concerned about I
just uh what are we doing what are we
doing guys thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast